when it comes to technology kids today
have got it made they never had to worry
about finding a friend in a phone book
or rewinding VHS tapes before bringing
them back to the rental store if you are
a first-time viewer click the red
subscribe button because today we are
discussing pending kids today don't
recognize beepers and pagers back in the
day pagers or beepers were like today's
kids equivalent of cell phones which
meant if you didn't have a pager by the
time you were in high school you were
probably the odd man out but what was
the actual purpose of pagers it's not
like there were a lot of teenage doctors
running around needing to be on call
even if you did get paged you would have
had to use a payphone just to call the
person back because you definitely
didn't have a cell phone
phonebooks before the world had Google
or services like Yelp we had phone books
if you wanted to actually cultivate
friendships you would have to look your
friend's name up in the phone book most
of the time it would be under their
parents name so you'd have to figure
that out too even if you wanted to order
something as simple as pizza
you'd have to whip out the phone book
luckily today you don't have to memorize
every important phone number and if you
need to reach a friend you can probably
do so on social media rotary phone not
only our landlines becoming near
obsolete the phones that once used
landlines are too the rotary phone looks
like an ancient artifact these days not
only is it a phone with a cord but where
all the buttons it would take at least
two minutes to dial someone on a rotary
phone and that's if you didn't mess up
if you got one number wrong you'd have
to hang up and start the long process
all over again
heaven forbid someone or a business have
a number with a bunch of ones or heroes
Walkmans and dismiss
when it came to portable music there
weren't many options back in the day
between Walkmans and discman tonight
there were exactly exercise friendly
these small machines would play either
CDs or cassette tapes but they were
pretty bulky try jogging down the road
with something the size of a small DVD
player in your pocket or attached to
your arm not only did the size get in
the way but if a CD was scratched or any
sort of jolting movement happened your
song would skip over and over VHS
players not only wear VCRs or VHS
players the only way to watch movies
they would actually destroy the movies
over time if you had a favorite movie
you would run the risk of watching it
until it just stopped playing if that
wasn't enough VHS players could
completely eat the film tape in the VHS
cassette which is how you watch the
movie when this happened you have to
carefully and manually wind the film
tape back into place and hopefully the
movie was still intact
dile internet access just having
internet service way back when was a
luxury and the only way to get access
was through a dial-up internet
connection that man's that your internet
was connected to a telephone line and
that's how you cruise the web it took
forever to access and the noises it
would make are so recognizable to older
generations
[Music]
also he would actually have to wait for
someone to get off the phone if you need
to play online but nothing could be
worse than getting kicked off the
internet just because your mom picked up
the phone waiting for photos kids today
have such easy access to photos that
they had become photo obsessed if anyone
wanted to take a selfie twenty years ago
it would have taken two to three days
just to get it back not only that but
the person developing it would have to
see your potentially awful selfies
then if you wanted to share the photo
with your friends online what you
probably didn't have you'd have to use a
photo scanner to scan it to a computer
file taking the photo of your food
wasn't even worth the process back then
tape decks if you had a car with the
tape deck thirty years ago you were
lucky this meant you could actually be
ready in time to record your favorite
music from the radio onto your blank
cassette if you still have a car with
the tape deck there is a pretty good
chance today's kids will have no idea
what it's for they may think it's an
auxilary player and try to steal their
phone in it no worries it will just be
another opportunity to tell them how
lucky they are they didn't have to
fiddle with cassette tape floppy discs
from storing homework to holding the
world's most important information
floppy disks were a big deal they used
to be able to hold so much information
as super villains and cartoons and
movies would steal them from governments
in order to destroy the world now the
notion seems almost laughable
floppy disks only store about 1.44
megabytes per disk which means today's
average smartphone holds about sixteen
thousand times more information than a
floppy disk would of video rental stores
years ago if you wanted to see your
favorite movie or new releases
chances are you drive down to the video
rental store to rent one you'd be given
a rental for two to three days and you
better return it on time or suffer the
consequences fees today it is so much
easier to have access to movies because
companies like Netflix means a video
rental stores obsolete at least kids
today never have to wait two
two-and-a-half minutes it takes to
rewind a movie after watching it
what are some more things kids today
don't recognize react in the comment
section below and don't forget to like
this video and subscribe to the things
you